next question that came in, David, for all
of the failed talk about a civil war after
the election results, what could actually
start a second American civil war?
So let's talk about this in a couple of different
ways.
First of all, a lot of times when people talk
about an American civil war or the division
of the United States into two countries, they
are talking about red states, blue states.
And the difficulty of that is that the geographical
boundaries of what red state, blue state would
be are relatively loose in the sense that
many red states still have 30, 35, 40, even
45 percent Democratic voters.
Many blue states still have 30, 35, 40, 45
percent Republican voters.
So this idea, you know, it's not a requirement
for a civil war that the lines be super clear.
If you look at Italy in the early 40s, you
had this north south thing, but the north
was filled with those sympathetic to the south
and vice versa.
You can look at sort of modern civil war,
Syria and Ukraine, they are more really sustained
sectarian insurgencies than clear civil wars,
the way we had the union in the Confederacy
in the American Civil War.
The other really interesting thing to consider
is that just for the sake of a thought experiment,
if we want to think about a second American
civil war, a long Confederacy Union lines,
the Confederacy is completely financially
unsustainable.
And we've talked about this before in the
United States.
You have all of these federal programs into
which states pay and out of which they receive
benefits.
They receive money.
The blue states dramatically subsidize the
red states.
And so you have a lot of states in the U.S.,
overwhelmingly red states run by Republicans
that were it not for being subsidized by money
from blue states, they wouldn't be viable.
And what you would have if you were to divide
the country in the imaginary second civil
war into factions that sort of line up with
civil war, union and Confederacy.
If there were to be a separation, the Confederacy
would be in 2020.
They would be bankrupt very, very quickly
and it would be a desperate situation there.
So it also is, practically speaking, not going
to it doesn't it doesn't make any sense now
in terms of now that we've gotten all of that
out of the way, what could really get the
United States to boil over, maybe not into
what we would call a civil war, but sustained
and major sort of sectarian violence and and
fighting?
One of the things that corporations and the
financial sector and others are really effectively
doing in the United States is they have created
a situation where a lot of people are just
kind of happy enough being able to be on the
couch watching football on Sundays and living
their lives.
Not that everybody's lives are perfect.
There's tons of hunger, poverty, everything
in the United States, but there is enough
people due to cheap stuff from China and credit
card debt and all of these instruments that
are available.
You've got a lot of people who they're thresholds
for when they're going to go out in the streets
and do anything is really, really high.
And it creates a natural disincentive for
people to do it.
At the same time, low wages, the low savings
rate of the United States, the financial instability
that so many people experience also makes
it tough to go out in the streets because
you need to buy food the next day for your
family.
And if you miss a day of work and it's unpaid
and you're not going be able to do that, and
you need to be able to not have your car repossessed
so that you can go and drive and get the food.
The point is, this is a system that perpetuates
itself.
The status quo perpetuates itself by keeping
keeping people sort of just happy enough that
they would need a really high bar to be met
before they would go out fighting for anything.
And at the same time, you keep them in a precarious
enough position that they can't afford not
to work for very long.
That is how you preemptively and systemically
suppress an uprising.
So I don't know what the answer is about what
it would take for something to boil over,
to be almost like a civil war.
You also don't need everybody.
You don't need everybody either fat and happy
or in squalor to have enough people to really
cause chaos.
There's no doubt about.
That but it is actually difficult to imagine
what would rise to that level, I think that,
you know, if Donald Trump were to figure out
a way to steal the election, I think you would
see protests like we have not seen for I don't
want to say how long decades for sure would
it rise to a civil war?
I don't even know.
I'm curious to hear from you